Now, I'll run git push origin different-oil.
As you saw before, pushing the branch updates the pull request.
So, now the pull request can be automatically merged.
If I look at the changed files within the pull request,
I still only see my changes.
That's because this view, only shows changes that are present in my branch, but
not present in the master branch.
And Sarah's changes are in both branches now.
Finally, I'll leave another comment for Sarah, so
she'll know to take another look and make sure everything looks good now.
That's because GitHub will email Sarah, if I leave this comment.
But it actually, won't email her that I've updated the pull request, so
I want to make sure she sees the update